the job market continues to bring on
workers at a rapid pace here at home
businesses still looking for employees
good afternoon thanks for joining us at
four i'm kirsten joyce and i'm christian
casa as we begin with that consumer news
the labor department says
the unemployment rate in march fell from
3.8 to 3.6 percent the lowest level
since the pandemic started
the u.s economy also added 431 000 jobs
and the latest data shows there are a
near-record 11.3 million job openings
well despite the positive job numbers
will local employers tell us hiring is
still not easy joe moeller spoke to some
business owners about it he's live near
paradise and flamingo with what some are
doing now joe
owners thought this problem the hiring
problem would be over by now but they
say trying to find the right people for
the right job is still proving to be
difficult many businesses are trying to
get creative silver 7's here there's a
sign that rotates right under the the
sign there that says now hiring and
offering bonuses
online it is easy to spot job openings
offering hiring bonuses this is north
las vegas offering bonuses for pool
staff the cosmopolitan is hosting a job
fair next week also offering bonuses
sami ledecky opened a new restaurant in
the southwest valley friday called
toasted he says the hiring pool has
changed it's not
still the same like it used to be
i don't know what these people want i'm
just wondering many employers are
changing what they are offering hourly
george malouf owns a number of ben and
jerry ice cream shops around the valley
he's made more promotions available for
employees to move up we have an entry
level position and then you know within
a month or two they can give themselves
a raise by taking out some additional
responsibilities and we've got like
three or four levels
back out here live another look at the
silver seven signs there it keeps
rotating but it's saying i'm now hiring
offering those bonuses like many
businesses getting creative doing one of
the business owners i did talk to today
says
he normally has a now hiring sign they
put out but they're leaving it out right
now it's just in case they need to get
workers at any time because they say it
is so difficult reporting live joe
mohler live local now thank you joe we
are always tracking the job market for
you we've put together a list of
companies hiring and links to apply
check out our website 8newsnow.com just
click the job board tab